all right my name is Jason i am the vp
of trust and security at a company
called bugcrowd at bugcrowd we host
manage crowdsource security solutions in
particular bug bounty and responsible
disclosure programs but I'm also a
tester and I've been a pen tester my
whole life and I continue to be a bug
hunter and this presentation basically
goes over a whole bunch of bug hunter
tips and tricks as well live oh no
really as well as vulnerability classes
that are pertinent in today's bug hunter
type of life cycle any of you hunt bugs
on a bug crowd or any vulnerability
disclosure program or anything like that
hacker one cynic couple you yeah
hopefully this will have some good stuff
in it this is kind of a year of parsed
knowledge basically so I did one of
these at Def Con 23 what I did is I took
all of the top hunters back then they
didn't have a lot of blogs there was not
a lot of information and and we took all
of their methods from their blogs and
disclosures and stuff like that tried to
distill them back to how they test and
how they found big quality bugs and then
what automation and tooling was good in
those sections and so that kind of
turned into this talk that I gave at Def
Con and so the idea is I redo this every
year with the new pertinent bugs that
basically high quality high-impact bug
bounty hunters find on programs to help
the rest of us get up to there so the
first version of the bug hunters
methodology had things like discovery
and mapping and parameters off an attack
and this one will have those things -
its up for revitalized with new data new
tools new fuzz strings filter evasion
technique stuff like that the
vulnerability classes I covered in the
last presentations were things like
sequel injection cross-site scripting
file uploads C surf and privilege some
of those are going to be the same and
some of them have changed in the two
years since I did this talk at Def Con
so we're gonna talk about some of those
so in this years we're gonna do more
discovery a lot of discovery and I'll
talk about why that is advents and
cross-site scripting a new vulnerability
ish class called server-side template
injection server side request forgery
some advents in code scanning for code
injection command injections and just
some general advents and web fuzzing and
then infrastructure and configuration
so when you're doing bug hunting you're
getting into ethical hacking or anything
like that there are some books that
you'd really need to put on your
bookshelf one is the web application
hacker's handbook and this is considered
kind of the Bible for the web
application hacker handbook it really
breaks down the methodology the syntax
all of the attack techniques and it's
written by the authors of a tool that we
all use in web application hacking
called burp burp suite proxy after that
shortly following that is the OS testing
guide at the bottom and that's a you
know referenced by Oh wast it has
basically a list of all types of
vulnerabilities and how to check for
those now they're having a couple books
I really recommend adding two to your
kind of bookshelf for this and one is
web hacking 101 by Peter your ski this
book is actually really awesome it goes
through a whole bunch of disclosures of
his bugs and other people's bugs on the
hacker one platform because they have
disclosure breaking into security by
Andy Gill and modern web penetration
testing which is a PAC publish book so
these three are kind of add-ons from the
last presentation that you should have
in your bookshelf if you're going to do
modern web application assessment so the
first section of this presentation is
all about discovery and the idea here is
that if you look at the cross-section of
our researchers you can think of them or
bug bounty hunters you can think of them
in a triangle right and at the top we
have the heavy hitters the guys that get
paid 10k a bug very regularly they do
this for a full time right they have a
certain set of skills if you take their
submissions and reverse them out down
into what vulnerability classes they're
finding so we wanted to find out well
how are they and what classes of bugs
are they finding at that top of that
pyramid so we can get the middle of the
pack up there right that's what we want
as bugcrowd
so one of the things that we found is
really good hunters are really good at
finding a tack surface that was unknown
which I call discovery so what this is
is finding websites that your
development crew stood up for two days
and never took down lawful offline
things like marketing sites that
marketing stood up never took offline
internal systems that have been left out
there I think there's a term called for
it called like shadow IT basically these
are all those systems that everybody has
forgotten but are still connected to
your cloud infrastructure
or even your real infrastructure so this
is a methodology that is parsed from
myself and a whole bunch of other people
discovery is actually one of my
specialty areas and it goes through how
to find lost and orphan sites because
they are often less secured than the
main comm and you can often find really
juicy vulnerabilities for these sites so
in the last version we talked about a
couple of things which was sub domain
scraping we talked about a couple of
tools and we're gonna talk about advents
in these toolings and then also as some
of the other stuff that goes along with
them so when you have this idea of
finding domains that are left out on the
internet that no one remembers or that
you just kind of want to find all of the
application space for one of these
companies the first thing you want to do
is called subdomain scraping and
subdomain scraping basically goes out to
all these sources on the internet like
certificate certificate repository as it
goes out to search engines like Google
and Bing and Baidu
and basically it search for your main
searches for your main domain here like
Tesla Tesla has an open bug bounty so
they you know let us show all the tools
running against their domain here and
you can see here that this tool will
look in Bing Yahoo Google ask net craft
pns dumpster virustotal SSL certificate
repositories and passive DNS the web
site and it will look for anything that
has Tesla com associated to it and any
of those sources and it will parse them
out and give you a list of everything it
finds so this is a tool called sub
lister that combines all of those into
one tool it's made by a hunter called
Abu Leia I think that's right Abu Leia
something like that excuse me if I put
your names and it hasn't been updated in
a little while if you look at this
repository for sub Lister there's
actually a fork maintained by another
author that actually has a few more a
few more parsing methods other than
being Baidu asked and all the ones that
are listed here so if you just go to the
github and go at the forks look at the
most updated one and that guy actually
has some checks here to see where these
redirect by IP and then also if they're
associated to any places where you could
possibly hijack the subdomain which is a
vulnerability we're going to talk at the
end of the presentation about which is
hijacking subdomains
so this is search engine basically
scraping and so sub Lister is one of the
main tools to use here for for finding
orphaned sites so in subdomain scraping
this is one method of discovery right
there's lots of methods you have two or
three tools that are really pertinent in
this area so you have sub lister on the
right here and then you have another
tool set called Recon NJ recon ng made
by Tim tomes and it's recon and G is
actually a whole ocean framework to do
discovery on people places domains it
can do oceans on anywhere and then I
wrote a tool that wraps around recon ng
called enum all with this guy leaf right
here he actually he did most of the
coding I just managed it and and it does
it does these three on the Left SSL
tools comm it parses from their API
hacker target comm it pulls data from
their API and showed on there are some
optional modules at the bottom zoom I
threat crowd just a generic zone
transfer the risk IQ API if you own an
API key for that and census that I do
which if you own an API key for that you
can pull down with recon ng I'm so are
there there are some that are specific
to each tool and a lot of people end up
using both of them oh and then both do
the middle column so luckily people
realize that you didn't want to use you
don't wanna have two tools and one so
they made a docker container called
brute subs which basically wraps these
two tools and one other one called alt
DNS which we're going to mention soon
into one docker container that runs from
one command because all you want to do
is really search one domain for one
command parse all of these different
input sources and get a list of stuff
that you might want to hack on for bug
bounties so this is that docker
container and it's pretty simple just
docker compose with your up and then you
have to set a config file with your
target and then it runs all these tools
on your on your target so here you can
see it's going through and using
multiple tools and it'll concatenate the
results so that's called brute subs
so that's subdomain scraping that's
pulling from all these sources on the
internet to find stuff that's either
been cached by a search engine it's been
sometimes somehow leaked via certificate
something like that there's another
couple of ways to do this which are
pretty cool as well so anybody in here
use CloudFlare some of you right so you
know when you start up CloudFlare for
domain they ask you for your domain and
then they do like this magic wizard that
shows you all of your sites right they
have this giant database at CloudFlare
already mapped out of the Internet they
know where your domains are what your de
namespace is and what IPS are associated
to those domains and they're ready to
deliver you CloudFlare on all of those
well as bug hunters we created a script
to go through that login cycle and parse
their data set and pull it back into the
stuff we should attack so this is
CloudFlare enum
so here's Disney I didn't run this sorry
if you work at Disney um this is from
the main page sorry and so you give it
your credentials for CloudFlare you just
create a fake account and then you give
it your email your credentials and then
it tells you what the CloudFlare magic
database comes back with this one
actually gives you some pretty good
information there's another project
called census do some of you might use
and there's a script to parse that as
well these haven't been integrated into
an automated tool yet but they will be
really shortly they'll actually part of
the new fork of sub lister which I'm
helping with so so that's sub scraping
getting getting subdomains from a whole
bunch of sources that are out on the
internet and trying to list them out so
you can attack them and find the juicy
ones where the good vulnerabilities are
there's also this idea of subdomain
brute forcing right so you have Tesla
com and then you just try to resolve
admin that Tesla dot-com and if that
doesn't work you try to resolve customer
service Tesla comm right and this is
brute force this is brute forcing the
subdomain part of the domain there's
multiple tools that have existed for
this for a long time right some of you
might have heard of fierce which is
older but very common one taught in pen
testing courses really there's a new
class of this tool that have come out in
the last couple years that dramatically
increase the efficient
this type of finding basically so
there's two tools one is mass DNS and
one is gogo Buster and both of these are
brute force tools with the syntax listed
here and so I did a case study of how
long it took to run through a 1 million
one hundred thirty six thousand nine
hundred and sixty four line sub-domain
brute force list which I made I took
every tool that had ever seen do
subdomain dupe brute force saying I
catted it and unique it into one file
and I'm talking about stuff that's from
like fifteen years ago
I put it all into one file and I ran it
through some of these tools so you can
see the run time sub brute which is a
common one Totten pentesting classes
just air it out with this size of a
dictionary just couldn't do it go Buster
took about 21 minutes
mass DNS because it's a distributed
program written in C and it used mul it
uses multiple DNS resolvers to try to
resolve the DNS uses up to 150 took 1
minute in 24 seconds to run that whole
file now there are false positives in
this tool so depending on the resolvers
that are returning stuff sometimes
they'll just return yes that this thing
resolved for a lot of stuff that didn't
resolve so you'll get false positives
but the thing you'll notice about the
false positives in the output of mass
DNS is that they're pretty pretty easy
to spot because they all return like
these generic like cname errors in the
tool and so you'll know right away that
they're false positives and you can just
grab them out so mass DNS and as a
backup go Buster are the tools that you
should probably use for subdomain brute
forcing and this is the hardware I use
for that case so at the bottom and
you'll have to excuse me I've been sick
like all week so I'm trying to you know
persevere ok so we talked about
subdomain brute forcing this is the
combination of basically all of those
word lists for the brute forcing I just
called it all dot txt it's a gist at
this address you can grab it I use it in
my pen testing all the time this is like
every program that's ever done DNS brute
forcing on the right here just put those
all into one list unique tit and so now
you have that for your own usage mass
DNS is at blech Schmidt that's where
you can pull down nasty and ask to do
some of this and so those are those are
two advents and kind of subdomain
brute-forcing in that part of discovery
in addition when you have a bug bounty
that is open scope enough like Tesla's
Tesla's is basically any system that you
can verify that Tesla own is included in
their their bug bounty you can check for
acquisitions for some of these programs
as well as in Facebook in Google but
they have a wait period they have like I
think it's maybe three months after they
acquire a company you might need to wait
until you submit it to their bug bounty
and I'm assuming that's how long it
takes them to migrate IT over to
Facebook or Google I can't remember
which one in the wait period is on but
once you do that you want to have mapped
out that hey look Tesla acquired groomin
engineering Solar City and Riviere tool
over the course of their lifetime are
all those assets that might be related
to a company that Tesla now owns have
they been tested
have they been hacked do they have
bounty related vulnerabilities on them
maybe maybe not so CrunchBase is the
place to go for this CrunchBase has a
lot of financial data related to
acquisitions and stuff like that so you
can go to crunchbase and pull down
related acquisitions so then after you
have all of these hosts via subdomain
scraping brute-forcing maybe some
acquisitions and when you find the
actively acquired companies in their
domains you put them back through the
subdomain scraping and brute forcing you
finally have this large list of targets
maybe you want to go after now you have
to port scan because to not port that
port scan them would be unfruitful what
happens a lot of times is these things
have remote administration protocols
open on them they have web servers
running on high ports that people don't
even think to look out for so you know
in the traditional kind of web testing
method you would use nmap to scan and
65,000 host with nmap this is a large
targets ASN or maybe a large discovery
from the methods we just mentioned
before that just takes forever
it'll just like put you to sleep if you
want to test all ports or even just the
default and month and map ports list for
this you might as well wait a month for
that type of scanner maybe a week maybe
maybe a week some a scan is a solution
to this problem distributed written in C
actually not distributed written and see
way faster higher higher error tolerance
on the scanning so this is the syntax
for running masscan against 65,000 hosts
with the default end map port range
you'll need some serious hardware in the
cloud to probably do this so I I
commissioned a digital ocean box with
plenty of memory and bandwidth but time
to run 65,000 hosts with the default end
map scrip ort list 11 minutes which is
not that bad
for this so pretty amazing alright so
you have a port scan you have a whole
bunch of domains with ports on them that
are open you're ready to hack them now
you need to know which one of these
domains that you pulled down earlier are
worthy of attacking first some of those
sources that we pulled from might have
been taken offline because one of them
was search engines right in search
engines cache old information sometimes
so some of those domains might have been
pulled off line some of the domains
might exist as a DNS entry but they
might redirect to the main Tesla comm
site so how do you how do you account
for that in your recon well you can use
it to like eyewitness which basically
takes a list of everything you have
which is at this point domain names and
subdomains and appends HTTP and HTTPS
tries to resolve each one of those and
takes a screenshot of each site after
all the resolving has taken place and
all the redirects to have taken place
then you get a folder like this on the
right which has all of the basically
pictures of what it landed on and you
can start to get a good feeling as to
what you want to hack first obviously if
you land on something that's like an
admin page or a developer console or a
login you want to check those out if
it's just the Tesla normal home page
that you're supposed to land on probably
not going to prioritize that right away
all right so now you have domains ports
prioritized places to test via like
visual identification now you kind of
want to do some platform identification
and to see if any of their web server
software or components are outdated
these will provide quick wins and
bounties if those vulnerability is
associated to old versions in their
server software or their third-party
code is
is something you have to do any work
basically you'll see that they're
running an old version of something
you'll go google it you'll see okay
here's the exploit for that and you'll
exploit it and you don't have to do any
work yourself so there's a couple of
things from the first presentation we
talked about this tool called retire j/s
which will go through third-party Java
JavaScript libraries and tell you if
nodejs is out of date and has
vulnerabilities associated to it for
technology mapping to see what a site is
actually running on the server side what
stack it's running there's Apple Iser
and built with and now there's a new
burp plug-in called vulnera sanentur
vulnerable
that as you passively visit sites in
burp instead of just giving you
basically the application level
vulnerabilities it'll also start parsing
version numbers that show up in read
Me's in the headers everywhere and tell
you that there's vulnerabilities
associated to anything behind the
version they're running at so burp
vulner scanner is a new tool to kind of
identify some of these easy c V's that
already exist okay so none of that
substitutes for actually walking the app
right like a lot of bugs are are highly
contingent on knowing what your
application does very intimately
especially things like insecure direct
object reference or missing function
level access control those type of bugs
very contingent on you actually using
the site instead of just using all this
automation so I put the slide in here
just to say like don't forget to get
very cozy with your app and understand
what it's doing these are ways to expand
your scope and to do discovery but once
you land on that site that you're gonna
hack really put your effort into it
alright so once you're on an app that
you want to start hacking though one of
the first things that people have done
is use a tool called der bust or even to
use der Buster force and unwashed tool
cool so it is a directory boot for sir
so we have Tesla comm right now in order
to discover everything that might be on
Tesla comm I spider it and I see it has
all these URLs and parameters and it
does certain things but there are hidden
things that it might do hidden admin
panels hidden parameters stuff like that
that might exist on that site
so we brute-force a whole list of common
common pages for that type of stuff now
traditionally der buster was the tool
that you would use for this now there's
a tool called go Buster which is written
in go it's much faster I didn't need to
do like a basically a comparison for
this because it's this has just kind of
been what we switched to and I think a
lot of people are aware of go Buster
already so but go Buster is a tool you
use for content discovery or directory
brute-forcing now burp has this idea -
it's called content discovery it's
available in the pro version of burp not
everybody has the pro version of burp if
you do have the pro version of burp
you're counting on that the word list
that they're brute-forcing in the path
is as good as the one that comes with
with go Buster or the ones that are out
in the open source community for route
forcing these types of paths the best
one right now that exists for doing this
is called robots disallowed it's one of
the best it's written by Daniel me sir
who's sitting right there so he
maintains basically you parked parsed
like the alexa top of what like million
or something yeah he parsed the whole
licks a list of their robots.txt files
and then sorted them by occurrence so
robots.txt meaning that developers don't
want you to know or go to those pages so
that's exactly what we're gonna go to so
you feed this thing to go Buster you
feed this list to go Buster and you find
things that developers didn't want you
to go to hopefully things that are juicy
and that have vulnerabilities associated
them so then there's the idea of like we
found pages that are good that we want
to attack and we want to fuzz and that's
general web hacking is putting stuff
into parameters or input fields and
seeing what happens but there's the idea
that there might be hidden parameters
associated to pages or functions or
scripts and so there's even a tool to
brute force parameter names if you're
with an API or with you think there's a
hidden parameter something is called
pram F and it's written by a guy named
Syrian Mach o he's a bug hunter and so
this will brute force parameter names
burp the authors of burp suite did a
project as part of something else that
they did which mapped the top parameters
that applications use the parameter name
so ID action page name
and they mapped all of these by
occurence so you can feed these two
parameters like an API or something like
that this can be either like the syntax
of you know poor script question mark
equals parameter or something like that
or it could be the you know the rest
style or whatever you could do either
but you can brute-force parameters with
but these type of tools so this is the
overall discovery methodology right
identify IPs and mein Teil these scrape
brute force ports can do some visual
identification identify the platform do
content discovery and then maybe do
parameter discovery so this is most of
the active stuff there is there are some
other stuff that you can do as part of
recon which is like trying to
investigate github repositories
associated to companies and map out
their technology that way and find paths
and even deeper parse javascript files
that the company's hosting to pull up
pads that are there those are new
advents and kind of mapping sites but I
didn't include those in here but they're
actually in a presentation that Ben
wrote for LevelUp that was like six
months ago or eight months ago and he
did a whole presentation on a couple of
those methods right so cool so one of
the topics in the last one in the last
bug hunters methodology was cross-site
scripting so we're gonna talk about a
few of the admins and cross-site
scripting so not really a lot of advents
and cross-site scripting cross-site
scripting remains the same except for
the addition of a quasi new category so
and I'm just gonna draw myself as an
example here for the longest time I was
pen testing for years throwing in attack
payloads into parameters and and boxes
input boxes that I was shooting alert
payloads into right and I was getting
cross-site scripting and I felt great
but for years I was missing out on the
fact that if I would have had a little
bit more JavaScript a little bit more
experience I could have added what's
called a JavaScript hook and then when I
sent a cross site scripting payload into
a form I might not have gotten immediate
response from my page but someone in
customer service for that come
might have eventually seen that a tack
string and it would have popped up on
their internal customer service admin
portal so this is a category of
cross-site scripting called blind
cross-site scripting and there's a
couple of frameworks here to manage and
test for blind cross-site scripting so
one of them is called sleepy puppy it's
built by the Netflix team anybody from
Netflix in here yeah awesome tool so
sleepy puppies awesome there's some
other ones there's ground control by
Gilbert Alma Amba you see your words
last name sorry
and then there's XSS hunter which is a
framework for managing the callbacks for
this there's also some things called
polyglots which have come around which
are basically identifying cross-site
scripting using one string that will
execute in multiple contexts which helps
you quickly identify some versions of
cross-site scripting and there's there's
some other resources here so this is the
idea blind cross-site scripting so this
is Franz and Franz in step one finds a
form field for a name last name and
organization Franz puts in a script like
this it says script source equals y dot
VG which is his domain he owns and so
when anyone visits that and that script
executes it will call back to his yvg
domain and he'll know that someone saw
that immediately he sends it through the
tubes and it ends up that he doesn't get
an alert right away so there's no stored
cross-site scripting there's no
reflected cross-site scripting but all
is not lost for Franz so eventually it
ends up on Jamie's computer and he works
for Yahoo and he has a customer service
portal he logs into every day that reads
emails or an application parses that
information and it pops up on Jamie's
admin console then it executes a shell a
JavaScript shell back to Franz a server
yvg and then Franz now has the same
access as Jamie can instrument his admin
panel this is blind cross-site scripting
so so sleepy puppies really good ground
controls really good but the one that a
lot of hunters use is actually XSS
hunter so XS enter XSS hunter is a
framework
that instruments blind cross-site
scripting it generates hooks for you it
will also email you when you get blinds
cross-site scripting triggers when those
customer support reps actually open the
email will email you it will send you
reports it has the ability to basically
parse and change the payload it does a
lot of cool tricks like beef and XSL XSS
shell used to do when we were doing like
demos of that so XSS hunter is kind of
the the framework that would you would
use nowadays to manage cross-site
scripting attacks for applying across
site scripting okay so in the last
presentation we talked about this idea
of polyglots and we you can look it up
it's a from Def Con 23 we talked about
three of the most common XSS polyglots
the idea of an XSS polyglot is that it's
one long string that can execute in
multiple contexts so if you put it in a
form or a parameter wherever it lands on
the page in the HTML as long as there's
not sufficient output encoding it will
alert you don't have to fiddle with it
to get it to match the context of your
page you just paste in this one string
and it should ignore all the parts that
it doesn't care about and alert on the
part that it does care about so there
are four main one of these that exist
this is one by hack fault called the
ultimate XSS polyglot it's not actually
the one I use them the most the one I
use the most is part of the old
presentation by a it was invented by a
guy named azshara to ved a lot of
scanners are starting to Institute
polyglot payloads because they don't
send as much traffic to the sites and
they don't have to worry about context
and some of their scanners so it's kind
of where some of that fuzzing is going
these days if you're really into
manually mapping context for cross-site
scripting there is a new resource out
there called the XSS mind map by Jack
Massa and what this does it's a giant
mind map of cross-site scripting
payloads based on context so you can
drill down if it's you know lands in the
Dom if it's part of Flash if it's part
of react or jQuery frameworks if you're
trying to bypass or
stay under a character limit there's
basically notes or actual payloads to
use against that type of context and
examples um so this is one of the new
resources that's really cool for for
cross-site scripting not that any of
these are new but definitely organized
really well okay so that's cross-site
scripting so now we're going to talk
about a vulnerability called server-side
template injection so there are a number
of template engines out there I use
flasks a lot for like you know easy
development projects to make CTF stuff
like that but if you use the templating
and engine there's there's the
opportunity that there could be a remote
code execution bug called server-side
template injection there now I'm not a
templating engine expert so I just know
that this vulnerability exists I've kind
of built CTFs around it before but I'm
not like 100% expert so so identifying
sites when they're using a templating
engine is is the same thing that we
would normally do you would use WAP
eliezer built with to verify the stack
on the server-side and see what they're
running you would fuzz parameters but
really there's a couple of tools here
when you identify that you're using a
templating engine Marco dust
you know Jinja any of those tornado and
this is the idea temple of a templating
engine right so here you have an error
page that's going to parse this URL or
when you get redirected to this air page
it's going to parse a your all here and
instead of providing it a parameter or
it's going to parse this page you give
it a math operator inside some mustache
braces or you ask it to read a file in
the second one here yeah
so there's an excellent article here I
have it in the resources page that
explains like axes actually how we're
finding out which class to use for the
file read here and this is against Jinja
but most of the time when i'm fuzzing
for SST i use the payload on the top
right what i want to do is usually I'll
have like a page or an input parameter
field of a nickname or something
that or whatever the parameter name is
or whatever and I'll just put in a
payload like two times three and if it
gives me back you know that if it evals
the math and gives me back page six or
gives me back six I know that I'm
probably you know good for server-side
template injection though there is a
tool called TPL map which is very
similar to sequel map which knows each
template in engine and how to construct
and find the class that we'll be able to
get you an operating system shell when
template injection is available so TPL
map here I've given it a URL that's
vulnerable and it identifies the
template injection in the name parameter
and then I tell it to get me the Etsy
password file and it's gonna do that in
a second so they're actually giving me
an operating system shell I did - - oh I
saw very similar to sequel map except
for all for templating injection and it
got me the OS command shell goes pretty
fast sorry so this is one of the bugs
that is like a p1 bug on most systems
new class of ish bug server-side
template injection was actually found by
one of the people on the burp team so
they have a whole white paper on how
this works so what we did at bugcrowd
this is actually off a little bit on the
style sorry it's from a different
presentation but I thought it was apt to
add into this presentation so what we
did at bugcrowd was we took all of the
parameters that were most often
vulnerable to this class of
vulnerability and ranked them by
occurrence and so what happens when you
build web applications or you end up
using these technologies as these
frameworks they either provide you
parameters or you think of one yourself
for the data you're trying to handle and
semantically it ends up being the same
parameter that's associated to a lot of
the same vulnerabilities so for
server-side template injection these are
the top parameters that are vulnerable
to this bug preview ID view activity
name content redirect and template
template makes a lot of sense right
templating engine template so for
debugging and logic which this slide
came in from another presentation but
for applications that where you want to
try to fuzz for debug or logic
functionality
in a URL as part of a parameter this is
that list on that side which is access
admin dbg debug edit etcetera etc so
this is part of another presentation I
did called hunt I made a tool to alert
whenever burp saw these parameters to
tell you to go test for certain classes
of vulnerabilities that's a whole
different presentation but I included
the tables in here so that if testers
really want to get intimate with these
type of bugs they know the places the
type of places to look so here are those
resources the original white paper for s
STI the s STI workshop that was done by
Jerome do you
SSST is STI in flask in Jinja by Tim
tomes really like I'm not an expert on
something I'm gonna try to give you the
best resource that you can go learn
about it so this is kind of what I do at
the end of each section so this is where
you would go and then pizza good friend
of mine so I put a little bubble here
say what's up okay so another
vulnerability that pays out well is part
of kind of the elite hunter kind of
methodology is server side request
forgery so server side request forgery
we didn't really talk about it that much
in the first version the bug hunters
methodology we're gonna talk about some
resources and tooling for it and this
one we're gonna move a little fast
because I'm running out of time so the
same as other places here's the table
for the most often attack parameters for
a server side request forgery file
folder location style locale template
path doc display you'll notice some of
them are the same for all the one our
ability classes that's okay I don't care
about that this is a very small handful
of params to test really or to be
alerted on so that's that list for you
the idea of SSR F is you have a function
on a website that takes normally takes a
path HTTP usually in most cases and it's
trying to do a redirect or pull some
kind of content from the value of that
parameter so you can see the value of
URL here is HTTP Google com well what if
you passed just last Google com what if
you pass it without the HTTP with the
protocol or the slash is what if you
pass it with just a path to something
else here
well you can do malicious things when
those functions are encoded correctly
like use the file protocol to read Etsy
password on the bottom or use TFTP to
internally port scan the server because
they haven't disallowed that protocol
handler in that's parser so there are a
whole bunch of ways to do this one of
the presentations I list in the
resources section is this presentation
by nicolas and it's a whole bunch of
ways to notate IP addresses or web
addresses that can get past blacklist
that people try to disallow this attack
in or a really you know whitelist any
type of you know pathing attack so these
are different ways that you can you can
do that you can bypass some some laughs
stuff really this is the ultimate cheat
sheet for SS RF it tells you by platform
or by a stack or programming language
basically which ones are vulnerable to
which protocol handlers by default um so
you can use this if you see a URL
basically my methodology is use burp if
you see anywhere in a parameter value
that a URL is getting passed or a path
is getting passed start to fuzz it find
out what platform it's on and then
referenced this cheat sheet what is
usually enabled by default on that
technology try to use those protocol
handlers and try to pull out bad files
these are the most common parameters for
server side request forgery
you can grab these slides offline so
I'll go through them and these are the
best resources for learning server site
request forgery okay I have ten minutes
so I'm gonna blast you this sorry so for
just code injection or command injection
or just kind of new fuzzing ideas in the
last you know whatever in the last
version talked about sequel injection
sequel injection not super like it
although it's a super impactful bug we
don't see it a ton like it's not a top
bug that we see a lot of testers finding
nowadays a lot of mitigations in sequel
injection but command injection funnily
enough still exists in a lot of a lot of
web applications and then the idea of
custom fuzzing as well is
thing that we see as well as I door or
missing function level access so this is
I doors the idea where you have a
numerical identifier inside of a URL and
if you incremented or decremented you
can get somebody else's data back right
that's an ID or ball bug so ID or still
retains its it's kind of king status to
bug all of our bugs ID or gives you the
highest payout applications are most
often vulnerable to it this is an
instance of a site here that was
vulnerable to an ID or that let you pull
down from a endpoint that gave you JSON
data on a customer and so basically all
you did was there is a ser ID parameter
and you incremented it by one or two or
three and it would give you back someone
else's data instead of your own this
happens all the time I don't think I've
seen a web application that has access
mapped very well that hasn't been hit by
an IED or before it's just it's super
prevalent people really there's no real
framework to fix access bugs so you know
they're usually pretty late in
applications so the things that you do
here to find I doors is look for you
know numericals in parameter values
which sounds like every every site is
going to have that but you'll know when
you see it's like ID equals or something
like that like you'll know by the
parameter if you should try to iterate
it or not if you see an email address
try to change it to a different email
address if you see a hash referencing
something try to change the hash create
two accounts and if one has a unique
hash as it's referencing an account just
steal the other hash see if you can
substitute it I'm a mix of some of these
exist on some of these sites these are
the most common parameters associated to
insecure direct object reference again
this is out of another presentation
called hunt that I did at DEFCON command
injection really that one's kind of been
covered a lot but there's a tool called
comics very similar to sequel map and
TPL map that exploits command injection
and it has the ideal it has the ability
also to give you reverse shells in
PowerShell or Python and integrate
directly in the Metasploit which is
pretty cool
there is some other advents that have
come out so burps sweets has an optional
module built into it now called
backslash powered scanner and what it
does is it doesn't actually fuzz for any
singular vulnerability it fuzz's by
applying just kind of junk in certain in
certain parameters and then escaping
them with the backslash and then reading
the response whether whether something
executed or an error came back or the
content type was different there's a
whole bunch of checks that he does but
it's kind of like automated manual
fuzzing that's what I call it and so
it's pretty powerful and it's a way to
get back to kind of manual fuzzing for
web vulnerabilities and when you when
Bert finds something that either returns
a different content type err or
something like that it gives you a
scanner check in and it says suspicious
input transformation you should check
this out basically so that's cool these
are all the resources for that section
last section how much time do I have
five minutes cool so the last section
where we see bug hunters succeeding and
finding big bugs is basically related to
infrastructure and configuration
vulnerabilities this is one that we see
a lot which is subdomain takeovers this
is the idea that you have a subdomain
that at one time connected to something
like one of these services and then you
let it lapse and so you still have the
subdomain mapped and what happens is an
attacker goes out and registers on one
of these sites your subdomain and since
you didn't you let it lapse they have
the ability to register it and then now
they have control of one of your domains
and inherit the trust of your users so
sub domain take over these are the ones
that can be efficiently efficiently used
basically you don't have to provide
credentials or IDs or company
verification to register those things in
most cases or you can forge it this was
made by was basically coined or made
popular by a tester named Franz Rosen he
has all these checks automated I don't
think anybody else really does she's
awesome I'm a pretty simple it's pretty
simple you know you check to see if any
see names are resolving to third-party
services and you make sure those things
are either active set up for you know
renewal and after and
renewed you nuke that CNN basically it's
a whole bunch of tools for this one
written by Ben here called hostile sub
root for sir although is is that
maintained still or not you anymore okay
yeah so use the originator but not the
maintainer TKO subs auto sub takeover
there's probably like six or seven tools
that are looking for this now because
it's an easy of all happens all the time
is usually a p1 on most platforms so it
gets you paid out at the top level it's
a big big time bug so misconfigured AWS
this is s3 buckets you read a lot about
these this is a whole probably day in
itself both hunting for s3 buckets that
are associated to companies and also
taking them over seeing if they're
configured right there's a couple tools
in this section and one called
sandcastle one called bucket finder and
there's some other ones that have
recently just come out that I haven't
used yet so just presentation needs to
be updated but there's a whole
walkthrough by detective I and Franz who
wrote about basically taking over s3 as
three sources basically so I'm not gonna
reinvent the wheel here you can check
that it's called a deep dive into AWS
three access controls taking full
control over your assets probably the
best reference and most complete
write-up I've seen on this type of thing
before the other one is get the idea
that you have get exposed off of your
main domain somehow there's a couple
tools for this called get Rob and
truffle hog that will basically pull
down source code repositories that are
left open the way you fuzz for this is
in your directory brute-forcing you just
add dot get usually and if you get a 200
ok on dot get it means they have
misconfigured usually get configuration
and you can try to download code that
they've left that on the internet or
through their repository that's it so I
got so some some resources the bug
hunters methodology the original one is
on my github so J haddock /tph em
there's also a forum for bug hunters
called the bug bounty forum and it's
associated to a slack channel so like we
all hang out in there and share
techniques and kind of make fun of each
other a lot so
you can check that out and these are all
the people that I pulled content from in
the presentation so you can check those
out in the thing and this is me if you
need to find me at J headaches or J
headaches about calm that's it
[Applause]